if you don't think that there is an
active attempt to control what
information is being seen by the masses
well then you're about to see something
that is so unbelievably disturbing that
you'll never forget it in fact this is
something that you can experiment with
on your own in about 30 seconds and
you'll see firsthand that there is
something quite disturbing going on
now let me just jump into this so you
can see exactly what i'm talking about
so here i am on google and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to type in a
controversial topic which is let's go
with
climate change as this is something that
is highly debated and as you can see
here at the top we have about 6.68
billion results in a little more than
half a second so
scroll to the bottom and what we're
going to do is we're just going to
scroll all the way over to page 10 and
notice that it still has
6.68 billion results but what we're
going to do is we're going to keep
jumping forward as far as they'll let us
go
and when you see what happens next
you're going to be quite surprised
so okay it goes to page 20 and then all
of a sudden you have just
194 results
where's the other 6 billion okay here we
go in order to show you the most
relevant results we have omitted some
entries very similar to the 194
displayed if you like you can repeat the
search with the omitted results okay
let's do that and as you can see we have
again 6.8 billion results in a little
more than half a second
so bear with me as we continue this
little exercise
as i assure you it will be worth the
wait
so here we go
right past page 20 and again notice so
here we are on page 22
still at 6.8 billion results
but let's just keep going and
unfortunately it only lets us go about
four or five pages at a time
but bear with me because
you'll see in just a moment what happens
we're already at page 38
and notice just and by the way we're
still at 6.8 billion results notice that
because that detail is going to become
quite important and notice that we still
have mainstream articles all the way
back bbc sky news
ani.edu
royal society all these dot orgs these
educational ones pew research
all right let's go to page 42.
still notice 6.8 billion search results
so let's keep going
whoa okay page 45 only 443
results well let's go back to page 44
and see what happens
again 6.8 billion it's back to
and notice we got different books all
about man-made climate change and we're
destroying the earth and all mainstream
articles
um in some youtube videos but notice
that
when you go back to page 45 it just
stops so i know what you're thinking
well let's just try a different topic
i'm sure you'll recognize this day
okay we have 8.46 billion results in a
half a second
let's do the same thing all over again
and i'll be as quick as i can okay look
it stops right there on page two goes
right down to 93 results okay let's just
deal with the omitted ones and as you
see we're at about roughly the same
amount 8.35 billion
and that's repeat the same exercise i'll
go as quickly as i can i know this is a
little tedious
but this is something that you'll soon
or you'll quickly be able to do yourself
on your desktop
and you'll be able to see firsthand just
how disturbing this gets and if you're
thinking that this is because
we are doing you know controversial
topics and in the age of disinformation
and conspiracies dangerous conspiracies
you know perhaps there is some sort of
limiting of information
but hang that thought because this is
going to become far more interesting in
just a second and especially to those of
you that think this is a google issue so
here we are page 44 and same thing
happens down to just a few hundred other
results and as you see we're on
mainstream articles npr politico
i mean
let's see here so just go back to page
43 so you see that it's the same thing
happening all over again
okay it is
so let's just type in something
completely benign i don't know what's
the first benign word that comes to my
mind
let's do pancakes which i don't eat and
you shouldn't either you'll you'll die
early if you do they're terrible for you
but here we go 399
million results okay
there's nothing controversial or you
know conspiratorial about pancakes
you can choose whatever word you want
but notice that we will again encounter
the same issue where it will try to
limit our results
based on
well hold on hang a second here now it's
going to do what i believe so here we
are page 23 220 results but again the
same thing happens right so okay no big
deal let's just go through the motions
again we're still at 399 million results
and bear with me this will only take a
couple seconds i'll scroll as fast as i
can because you need to see first hand
exactly what happens with your own eyes
so you can understand that there's
something happening on all the major
search engine platforms to control
information to the masses and again like
i was just saying this is not just a
google thing because bear with me i'm
going to show you the next largest
search engine in just a moment and i
want to show you how far this goes in
okay we're at page 34 still 399 million
it's only take another second
and if some of you are thinking that
okay i see where he's going with this it
limits itself once it gets to about four
dozen or all right hold on here we go
42 r a page 42 415 results and like i
was just saying if some people are going
to say well you know who who scrolls 40
pages in
not many people
but
i can tell you that here's an
interesting fact that on page one down
to the tenth result only two and a half
people or two and a half percent of
people click that far
um but okay so here we go again
pancakes just drops off the face of the
planet on page 42 415 results
guys i don't know when this started
happening
but it was not always like this i
remember seeing vaguely remembering
seeing people make videos about certain
topics and going a few hundred pages
even a couple thousand pages into google
to see what comes up
there was pages still there and
information to be found it wasn't always
like this i do not know when this went
into effect but something happened here
now like i was just saying this is not
just limited to google so let me go to
bing which is garbage i don't use them
but let's just do the same thing
all over again
all right so we got 2.9 billion results
and as you can see it doesn't let us
click as far in
but bear with me this will only take a
second
and
let's see here
it dropped down to 1.3 billion results
but that's okay i'm not going to
complain a billion results is more than
i can entertain
but wait for it
wait what happened what
what's this
let's go back so we were on page 13 and
then when you go to page 15
done so so let's go to page 14.
okay so we're on 175 through 185 results
out of 1.3
billion
as you can see we've got various
articles showing up here
some youtube videos some dot edu's
and it just goes away guys
gone
here let's do pancakes over here just so
you can understand oh i spelt it wrong
but it's okay we'll have it fix it for
us
okay it doesn't say how many results
there are but it'll show us on the next
click over all right so 77 million
results on pancakes
let's keep going
as fast as i can and i know this is a
little tedious
but it is worth it so you can understand
exactly what's happening here
so
wow okay so what page was that i wasn't
even looking
same thing
page 15 13 to 15
14 works as you can see you got some
wonderful articles on pancakes
so okay
let me show you a few things here first
of all where i had heard of this was
from a friend that sent me this
wonderful youtube video
and call or excuse me channel called
truthstream media and i've been
following them for a while and they had
made a video on this that i was not
aware of which is find it right here
hold on
okay
okay so here we are forgive me so where
did the internet go you need to watch
this video it covers the same thing i
just did but in far more depth and as
you can see it's got a hundred thousand
views but this is three months ago
and this should have way more views and
this wonderful channel creator she makes
outstanding content
and it's funny as i was looking through
i'm like where have i seen this channel
it's been a while since i've seen their
videos
and
when i clicked on most popular which is
what was open
wow if you saw my recent video on the
ancient conspiracy involving destruction
of iraq you would notice i played a clip
of this however the clip i showed you
was from a little channel that has like
only a few hundred views because when i
was trying to search this into youtube i
could hardly find anything
and then all of a sudden this video with
13 million views made seven years ago
has was buried and beyond any type of
way of me finding it see this is another
example even though i wasn't google
searching this or doing on a bing or
anywhere else even youtube itself is
bearing things because you got to keep
in mind that google and youtube is the
same company owned by alphabet bing is
microsoft and
i don't know exactly when it started it
was a year to two years ago or so where
the youtube recommended videos show up
in the you know the queue on based on
whatever topic you're looking at has
changed drastically and for the worst so
youtube announced that they were going
to crack down on conspiracies and
dangerous content and all that stuff and
keep people from going down these
dangerous rabbit holes right
but i've talked to many people about
this and it's only gotten worse they
start recommending videos that have
nothing to do with the topic and it's
pretty much just bores the hell out of
you like you just give up in other words
what they're doing is that if you are
not specifically looking for certain
information whether it's typing in on
google or youtube or anywhere else
you're not going to find it and i know
what some people are going to say like i
mentioned a moment ago like you're not
scrolling 40 pages in
well it doesn't matter because they're
just keeping you in a little truman show
box and go watch that truth stream media
channel and video because they make an
interesting argument about that which is
that they're just keeping us all in a
little box here guys you have your you
have your like say in the case of the
climate change people are saying yes us
humans are destroying it and you have
other people saying it's natural but
they keep each party because you're
wondering like how can people be so
divided on this topic well anything that
they're searching guys or keeping them
in their own little hole of like
thinking that they're right and these
people over here in their little hole
thinking that they're right
so
this
you know this channel that i was telling
you about truthstream media to make an
outstanding argument which is that back
in the early days of the internet it was
like the wild west but in a good way and
that if you search something in and you
type in exact words it would come up but
now you have to be very very specific
otherwise you'll never find a different
point of view so
i was born in 1984 so i'm 38
and i was high school class of 2002. so
these were like the pioneer days of the
internet i mean i remember when aol was
a thing alta vista yahoo is like i mean
yahoo's still around but it's who uses
yahoo uh but anyways and
guys i can tell you
and other people that are similar to my
age know exactly what i'm talking about
that things have changed so dramatically
and last that say a handful of years or
so
where
the controlling of information has
increased so greatly that it is ruining
it and and i know what some people are
going to say because they are not aware
of why the freedom of speech is so
important but they'll say well yeah we
gotta stop dangerous ideas and
conspiracies from going around uh i got
news for you
for the last several decades there's
been conspiracies and everything was
fine the world went around and round in
a circle in a wonderful way
and people had access to all the
information they need and everything was
fine and all of a sudden people are
pretending like there's this issue
involving freedom of speech and that
like trying to convince you that it's
not a good thing
the only thing dangerous
there's nothing dangerous about sharing
ideas and discussing things the only
thing dangerous is withholding
information from you that it provides
you from having a complete and total
perspective on what the truth may be
if there was nothing if this was totally
benign there would be no reason to hide
the truth from people
so that being said i am i've shared what
i wanted to share experiment with this
on your own i highly recommend that you
share this with everyone
you know because everyone you know uses
the internet so this applies to everyone
and the implications of this are
significant this is just one little way
of people being able to see that
maybe there is something going on
involving the sharing of information to
the masses so with that said i'm going
to close this up my channel or my name
is jimmy corsetti my channel is called
bright insight leave a comment and share
what your thoughts are on all of this um
and hit the like button and subscribe as
well uh like i mentioned in my prior
video i'm working on my next video on
atlantis which i'm quite excited about
but once i saw this
i yeah this is all i could think about
this is something that has to be shared
immediately because this is something
that everyone needs to know about
so all of that said i'll close it up
share your thoughts and all of this and
share it with other people but that said
my name is jimmy stay tuned for my next
video take care everybody